great news coming out of virginia
because the culture of death in virginia
is being dealt a very tough blow by
glenn yunken the republican governor of
virginia here the
man i thought was a kind of moderate
republican in virginia is now pushing
for a 15-week abortion ban in what is a
very blue commonwealth
you've said you've proposed a 15-week
ban will you ever pursue
a full ban on abortion in virginia
well the reality is that as a pro-life
governor
in a state like virginia
where i have a senate that's controlled
by democrats and a house that's
controlled by republicans
we have to find a way to get things done
and i believe that's what we've been
able to do is get things done at a time
where you have to bring people together
in order to make progress
as i said i believe life begins at
conception
in virginia we've got to work with a
senate and a house this is what we've
been doing but will you ever pursue a
full ban well i believe that what my job
is is to get something done and i
believe we can get a 15-week pain
threshold build done in virginia for the
first time think about it this was a
state again that just 18 months ago was
talking about enabling abortion all the
way up through and including birth and
now we're able to talk about a 15-week
pain threshold bill where a baby feels
pain this is a remarkable moment for us
and it's an opportunity i'm not going to
let go
great answer from glenn younkin here
he's not willing to take the bait and
give the democrats some big scare quote
people are going to point to this the
democrats are going to point to this and
say see he's not a moderate glenn
younkin's not a moderate he's a far
right wing radical republican
no he is a moderate he is still a
moderate
what's so amazing about this is that
the center has moved the center has
moved to the right the moderate position
on this issue has moved with the
overruling of roe v wade
this is where we always talk about
politics is downstream of culture well
this is a great example of culture being
downstream of politics this is a great
example of the law being a teacher and
shaping the culture and shaping the
democratic dialogue as well
back when roe v wade was in place
this 15-week abortion ban would have
been a radical far-right abortion ban
this would this would have been like the
mississippi law
that brought
that brought dobbs to the supreme court
in the first place
after the overruling of roe v wade
now the the
scope of the debate has broadened so
much rather than just trying to debate
okay can we ban abortion in 20 weeks or
18 weeks or 15 weeks now look there is
no constitutional right to an abortion
so now the question is do you want to
ban abortion entirely or do you want to
allow abortion entirely and glenn
younkin has staked out the moderate
position of a 15-week abortion ban that
just two months ago would have been a
radical far-right position this is great
news this is
largely thanks to
the pro-life movement in mississippi
certainly all around the country this is
thanks to those conservative justices
this is thanks to donald trump and other
republican presidents
who got those justices on the court and
this is thanks to the courage and
prudence of glenn younken
had dobbs not
not come down as it had had roe not been
overruled glenn younkin would not be
able to push for a 15-week abortion ban
now he has that ability i bet glenn
young can probably would
pass a total ban on abortion if he could
that's not where the commonwealth is
that's not going to work but now the
center has moved so we can do it so
let's keep pushing guys let's keep
moving that center further and further
and further because moderation is a
wonderful is a wonderful virtue we've
just got to make sure that the overton
window is such that moderation is in a
truly good
moderate virtuous place and it's not all
the way far out on the left like like
the left had shifted that window so so
far for for the past several decades
right now go to beam organics dot com
slash knowles you go to beam because i'm
about to give you a dream literally i'm
going to give you a dream did you know
that a poor night's sleep can cause
weight gain mood issues poor mental
health lower productivity some reports
say that less than six to seven hours of
sleep per night can lead to reduced
white blood cell counts white blood
cells protect our body against illness
and disease fighting viruses bacteria a
whole lot more not a lot of people
realize this but having a consistent
nighttime routine is very very important
a better tomorrow starts tonight it's
why you got to check out beam
dream beam is one of the world's most
innovative functional wellness brands
with unique products for everything from
sleep to focus today our listeners get a
special discount available for beam's
sleep product dream powder mmm their
best selling hot cocoa contains premium
ingredients triple lab tested you wake
up refreshed 98 percent of people
surveyed fall asleep faster when taking
beam dream 99 of people experience a
better sleep quality just mix beam dream
into hot water or milk stir enjoy before
bedtime they've got a brand new
delicious summer flavor of dream powder
sea salt caramel it's just absolutely
magnificent you can go check it out
right now if you don't love it you get
your money back guaranteed for a limited
time get up to 35 off when you go to
beam organics dot com slash knowles use
code knowles at checkout beam organics
dot com slash knowles use codenals to
check out for up to 35 off i'm really
impressed with glenn younkin i think
conservatives can learn a lot from glenn
younkin who is ruling
ruling with an iron fist no he's he's
governing as a conservative in a blue
state he's doing it pretty effectively
there are there are more
ways than one to skin a cat so you can
get things done through
orders from the governor's mansion you
can get things done through legislation
you get things done through the courts
and you can get get things done just by
running the bureaucrats out of power
300
virginia government bureaucrats have
quit
since may
what why have they quit in the last two
months they've quit because glenn
younkin
told them that they had to come back to
work
that was it he didn't pass some
draconian new regulation or rule he just
said okay guys you've been sitting at
home
for
two years now you have to come back to
work and 300 of them quit
employees from five different state
agencies resigned after yunkan's
new show up to work policy
and
they a lot of them cited the telework
options and the loss of telework options
as their reason for leaving this is
really smart an important issue that no
one is talking about zero people are
talking about but it was an important
issue in the early days of the
republican party and every so often it
crops up as an important issue is civil
service reform
it that that name doesn't sound very
sexy
but what we're talking about is
the administrative state the deep state
the the
career government workers who get to
continue to govern us
whether the elected people come in or
they go or they change parties or no
matter what happens to the electeds the
the permanent governing bureaucrats
remain
and
we need to reform that system
civil service needs reform every so
often it's a long past due for reform
right now one way to reform it
make them come back to work and then
they quit their jobs and then maybe we
don't replace them or maybe we institute
some new rules as to how we hire those
bureaucrats
personnel is policy the people who are
putting your policies into place have a
lot of power over how those policies
look so you got to make sure you've got
good bureaucrats in charge you're never
going to get rid of the bureaucracy you
can trim it around the edges you can
change the way it looks but you're not
going to get rid of the bureaucracy that
is a libertarian pipe dream it's not
going to happen so you've got to make
the bureaucracy work for you this is a
very very big country i'm not just
talking about virginia here we're
talking about a country of 320 330
million people there is going to be a
bureaucracy so how are we going to make
that bureaucracy work for us we can
reform the way people are hired we can
reform the kind of power that they have
we can reform the way that they can make
rules in the agencies but we've got to
do that because that is where so much of
the government actually happens it's not
usually just the bill up on capitol hill
and i'm going to something something
something it's not that it's not
schoolhouse rock okay it's not even just
the judges the judges have a lot of
power but most of the power is in that
bureaucracy so we've got to
got to take some lessons from glenn
younkin okay glenn younkin who won on
social issues by the way don't forget
that everyone's looking at glenn young
and the moderate he's the moderate
republican who's just talking about
taxes no when he was just talking about
taxes he was going to lose his race to
terry mcauliffe the democrat
he won when he started talking about
about critical race theory in schools he
won when he started talking about
transgenderism in schools and the
loudoun county rape story that actually
the daily wire broke not to suit our own
horn but that was a major issue for
flipping that race and handing virginia
to a republican governor it was the
social issues that's where people want
moderation we don't really care that
much about marginal tax rates people
don't i like low taxes but people don't
wake up in the middle of the night
sweating because of tax rates right now
if you tell me michael the democrats
might raise your taxes and also they're
going to pump your kids full of
cross-sex hormones and chop off his
genitals so
we're going to focus on the tax issue
right i'd say are you out of your mind i
don't give a damn about the taxes
compared to them transiting my kid
that's what republicans have to run out
that's where the real moderation is i'm
so glad you like that clip we are this
close this close
to a million subscribers and i can't
wait to get a million because i know
that's when youtube is going to nuke my
account i know they're just they're not
going to let me get that high so let's
do it baby let's accelerate head on over
ring that bell click ding dong like
subscribe whatever you got to do get the
notifications for our new videos we'll
see you next time
[Music]
[Music]